I want to start today's show with a
question that question is why now
President Obama and what I mean is for
the last nearly eight years at this
point eight years on January 20th 2017
I've criticized President Obama when
he's deserved deserved criticism I
praised President Obama when he has
deserved praise and today I need to
criticize him not because he said
something I disagree with not because
his administration said something I
disagree with but because once again he
waited until he had mere days left in
his presidency before saying something
that he should have said a very very
long time ago I reported to you a couple
of weeks ago that very casually during
one of his final appearances before
leaving the White House President Obama
said yeah we should be legal marijuana
should be treated like alcohol or
cigarettes and my reaction was well yeah
but why not say something earlier in
your presidency when it would have had
such a major impact on the legalization
drive that we are seeing particularly I
mean most acutely necessary now because
we have incoming attorney general Jeff
Sessions who will no doubt try to undo
the the progress that has been made with
regard to marijuana decriminalization
and legalization and that there were a
number of understandable explanations as
to why President Obama waited you know
you have to weigh the political reality
at the time and seven and a half years
ago if President Obama would have said
hey we'd should be legal just like
cigarettes and alcohol could have been
politically risky it could have
backfired and hurt President Obama's
ability to get other significant
legislation passed I get that I don't
like it I hate that this is where
politics is but at least I understand it
conceptually okay but now we have yet
another example of this President Obama
and his administration through a new
report have said what I criticize Donald
Trump for not saying during the 2016
presidential campaign what Hillary
Clinton didn't say during the 2016
presidential campaign
I must have pointed it out
must have been fifty times or more that
the real threat to jobs in America
in the next 15 to 20 years is not China
it's not Mexico it is artificial
intelligence automation and robots
taking our jobs the administration put
out a report a good report a report I
agree with a report that I think is
incredibly necessary right now that says
it's called preparing for the future of
artificial intelligence and it says that
driving jobs and housecleaning jobs and
so many part-time jobs for example just
in the transportation world this report
from the White House from the Obama
White House says that somewhere between
2 point 2 and 3 point 1 million jobs
will be threatened altered or eliminated
because of autonomous technology and
that's just in the driving and
transportation world similar to the
numbers I've talked to you about I have
been arguing that a paradigm shift is
completely necessary if we really want
to be prepared in a reasonable manner
for the change that is inevitable to our
economic reality we need to be thinking
not about can trump bring jobs back from
China and Mexico that his companies were
partially responsible for sending over
in the first place that by and large
don't even exist anymore that that is
not the right approach that's a
distraction that may appeal to trumpets
he believed that America is going to be
made great again by that type of
rhetoric but that's not the right
conversation we need to rethink and and
totally restructure education we need a
better social safety net for displaced
workers and maybe that means and I've
been talking about this for a long time
moving away from individual means-tested
social welfare programs each with their
own extremely significant bureaucracy
apparatuses aparadha actually don't know
what the right plural is they're
sounding like a hate reott today but
maybe we need to look at a basic income
that is not means-tested it can
eliminate all of that bureaucracy in
food stamps and Social Security all
these different areas and we're sort of
going in the opposite direction with the
Trump administration where a lot of the
welfare programs that should probably be
consolidated and expanded under the
coming automation revolution a lot of
those programs are under the chopping
block in the incoming Donald Trump
administration it's also not just
artificial intelligence and not just in
the industries that the Obama report
mentions if you look at 1950s science
fiction 1950 science fiction is
increasingly relevant in thinking about
what the 2025 or 2030 reality could be
you have the Utopia 1950 science fiction
and then you have the dystopian 1950s
science fiction and I call it 1950s
about 60 70s 80s there there's been
plenty of written we have the Utopia
under robots right which is robots and
artificial intelligence and machines
make us free to continue to reduce
scarcity when it comes to basic needs
like food and housing and just basic
even medications etc and humans can
focus on being productive in new ways to
society right improving thinking
improving innovation working on new
problems really digging into climate
change and it's impacts or they could
also just do nothing and still live and
contribute to society or just be parents
or whatever they want to do on the other
hand we have the dystopian version of
automation and robots and artificial
reality which is we continue to exist in
the same paradigm of crony vulture
capitalism and the automation revolution
leads to the destruction of jobs with no
paradigm shift about our relationship to
work increased poverty certainly
increased inequality and and probably
even more problems it could go either
way
I like the report from the Obama
administration but why now this should
have been discussed for a very very long
time thanks for watching this video
before you watch the next one remember
we're raising money to expand the David
Pakman show big league as well as expand
progressive
activism go to david pakman.com slash
donate donations of any size are much
appreciated